rehearsals are underway for TV's next a
live musical event the passion and you
have never seen anything like this
before
the stories are taking over New Orleans
and Michelle Turner got the first invite
to the set
I'm doing demons from imagine dragons
wow that's kinda dope with Jesus what
else you guys are doing it do it yeah
it's it's kind of a little back and
forth it's set in 2016 to modern day
music a twist on the Easter tradition
for many Christian faiths this
production of The Passion features stars
like tsiolis Pontius Pilate in Trisha
Yearwood as Mary the mother of Jesus
sixteen popular songs will be sung
including Celine Dion's love can move
mountains the mostly live show will
feature some pre-taped segments I
visited the set for one of them that's
Jesus played by Jim Carlos Cannella and
his disciples including judas played by
Chris Daughtry you know what well we're
here in his dope and it's all alive and
they're here and you work with one of
our favorite people in Hollywood Eva
Longoria yes when you told her hey guess
what you wanted to take a little time
away because I'm gonna go play Jesus
what is she oh you know Eva she's like
she's like oh Jesus what's great about
every single member of our cast is they
do they embrace their faith Tyler Perry
is the host and narrator he's excited
and has a message for religious skeptics
and we're staying very close to the
Bible and how can you go wrong when you
stay with the word yeah that can be a
sermon Tyler hey let me tell you about a
standout moment that you cannot miss in
this production during Jesus's trials
feel and Jencarlos sing a duet together
it's of a Tina Turner classic we don't
need another hero trust me it is a
showstopper it sounds like a lot of us
gonna be but yeah the cast the music I
mean the breakthrough New Orleans tells
us that we cannot dance the scope is
huge I can't wait